طيب دكتور سالنا الناس في مصر لماذا برايك
ارتفع بشكل كبير استهلاك حبوب الاكتئاب
عبر العالم نسمع راي الشارع ونرجع لك
دكتور
[موسيقى]
للاسف في ثقافه فعلا منتشره على الانترنت
وفي الصيدليات وفي غيره اقرب واحد جاي لك
بيقول لك انا مش عارف انام ادي له دواء
فيه ماده فعاله مضاده للاكتئاب لو بصيت
لنسبه ارتفاع الطلاق والنسب الانفصال
والكلام ده زائد الغله والكلام ده على ما
اعتقد يعني انت بتلجا لحاجه تهدي اعصابك
احسن ما تلقى للمخدرات
احنا بنبقى اكثر اجتماعيين وكده فبتلاقي
الكتاب قليل الجو الاسري بره مش مش موجود
بالدرجه الكافيه زياده
صاحبك او قريبك او كده تخلي الكتاب
كل واحد قفل على نفسه بقى هو اللي صاحبه
قفل على نفسه فاصبح في عز عن العالم
بالتالي بيجي له اكتئاب
[موسيقى]